graduates of the class of 2021
family members and friends it is a
privilege to speak with you as
part of this remarkable moment you're
probably feeling many emotions right now
i often tell graduates that commencement
is a field day for me as a psychologist
and
that has never been more true for over a
year
we have walked a strange and historic
path together
we are now at the end of an academic
year like no other
but although our traditions may look
different this year
they are just as meaningful as ever
commencement is a time of celebration it
is a
chance for you our graduates
to revel in your accomplishments it is
also an opportunity to reflect
and say thank you so many people have
been part of your journey to this moment
i hope you will find time to tell them
how much they have meant
to you i also would like to say thank
you
to you graduates of yale college
you have made history at yale many of
you have studied
and learned and made a community here
under extraordinary conditions
others have studied remotely from around
the world
day after day for more than a year
you have made sacrifices for the greater
good
helping keep our neighbors on campus and
in new haven safe
it has not been easy your bright college
years have
not always been what you expected
like people around the world you have
experienced loss
grief and uncertainty
and yet you have repaid our community's
trust and confidence in you
many times over
today as we look to the future i would
like to share a
personal story about my past and my
present
i share it because i hope it will shed
some light
on your future it is a story about
teachers
and the gifts they give us
in the early 1970s i was a student at
williamsville
high school north outside of buffalo new
york
it was a pretty typical large public
high school
we had a popular football team and a
marching band that played at the games
perhaps it will surprise you to learn
that i did not play on the football team
but i did march with the band
now you might wonder how i fit into a
school like this
i actually earned a varsity letter for
the drama club
i was part of another student
organization as well
a poetry club hosted by two beloved
english teachers
mr and mrs blaisdell a group of us would
gather in their home and
share poems we had written or come
across
we drank coffee we talked about poetry
it was all very grown up especially for
kids like us from buffalo
our teachers were only in their twenties
perhaps early thirties
but they were sophisticated adults and
therefore
seem much older to us they cared deeply
about literature writing and poetry
but most of all they cared about us
their students
in fact i'm not the only student of the
blaisdells on the faculty here at yale
they taught english to chemistry
professor scott miller about a decade
after me
fast forward 46 years
the kids from that poetry club now have
families and careers
of their own we have stayed in touch
but usually we only see each other every
few years
at best as a way of coping with the
social isolation of the pandemic we
started meeting
over zoom we shared poems
we drank coffee together again our
former english teachers from
williamsville north
now retired joined us
and we found in the midst of so much
grief and loneliness
a way to connect
what does this mean for you the
graduates of 2021
first my hope for each of you is that
you have made a friend here at yale
perhaps a few friends
will be there for you in 46 years
that is no small thing
second i hope you have found great
teachers
and developed interests that you will
take with you
for the rest of your lives i don't mean
only your professional interests
many of you without question have found
important mentors who will continue to
advise and guide you
but you have also found interests at
yale that have nothing to do with your
careers
for me it was poetry theater and music
but for you it may have been an
economics class or a history seminar
that made you re-examine the world
it might have been a certain psychology
class that helped you think about
happiness in new ways
or maybe you heard a lecture or attended
an event that sparked an interest in the
outdoors
or food or dance these moments of
inspiration and learning can happen
anywhere we now know that they can even
happen on zoom
my friends from williamsville north have
gone into music science
medicine law and theater i'm a
psychology professor and university
leader
my point is none of us are professional
poets
and yet our experiences in the poetry
club were transformative
from wonderful teachers i learned how to
ask different questions bigger questions
in high school i was always trying to
figure out what a poem was
about i wanted to unlock the secret
meaning
but mr blaisdell would tell me peter
what the poem is about is not always the
most interesting question
he encouraged me to appreciate beauty
and occasionally put aside analysis
he pushed me to use different parts of
my mind and my emotions
beyond poetry my teachers inspired in me
and my friends
a deep and joyful love of learning
they introduced us to interests that
made our lives richer
and more rewarding i recently had the
privilege of
interviewing the poet louise glick who
won the 2020 nobel prize for literature
professor glick has taught at yale since
2004.
she told me she thinks of teaching as a
way of repaying her debts
you can't thank your teachers she said
except by performing
as they did for another generation
soon you will leave yale and contribute
to
every field and profession as
generations of alumni have
before you you will leave here with
gifts from your teachers from yale
professors
from others throughout your lives
and as professor glick says you can
repay your teachers
by helping others discover the world
over the past year we have learned so
much about ourselves and
about what we are capable of and we have
been reminded
again and again that we must keep
learning
there will always be new challenges to
tackle
unexpected problems to solve we will
have to pivot
and adapt and if we love learning
if we are curious about the world and
the people in it
then that task will be so much easier
and more fulfilling
what will you do with the gifts you have
been given
what gifts will you give to the world
i think of emi mahmud a 2016 graduate of
yale college
born in darfur sudan emmy won the
international world poetry slam
championship
was honored by the bbc i met with
president obama
all while still a student at yale
emmy's poems often deal with her
experiences of war
and displacement today
as the united nations goodwill
ambassador she advocates for peace
and human rights particularly the rights
of children
she is sharing her gifts with the world
in a very powerful way
in the book tuesdays with maury the
sports writer mitch album
describes reconnecting with his former
professor
maury schwartz the elderly maury
is suffering with als lou gehrig's
disease
the book is an extended reflection on
life and death
but it is also about the relationship
between a student
and his teacher at the end album says
have you ever really had a teacher
one who saw you as a raw but precious
thing a jewel
that with wisdom could be polished to a
proud shine
if you are lucky enough to find your way
to such teachers
you will always find your way back
i hope you find your way back back to
your teachers
and back to yale i hope you will return
to campus and walk down chapel street
and enjoy the sunshine or the snow on
old campus
or science hill and i hope you will find
ways of sharing the joy of discovery
with others
i hope you will share your curiosity
with a world
that needs questions as much as answers
that needs light and truth
more than ever
i usually conclude my addresses on
commencement weekend
with a few words of verse over the years
i have read from
rabrinjanath tagore elizabeth alexander
billy collins marie boroff and claudia
rankin
but most often i have turned to the
words of john milton
from paradise lost you know those verses
about leaving the garden of eden
with wandering steps and slow and making
one's way into a world that is all
before you
there are moments when those lines move
me to tears
in this challenging year though paradise
does not seem the right metaphor for our
beloved campus
but i look ahead with great optimism and
i trust you do too
so perhaps these words of emily
dickinson seem more appropriate at
this moment hope is the thing with
feathers that perches
in the soul and sings the tune without
the words
and never stops at all
graduates of the class of 2021
you are ready to face the future with
optimism and determination
you are ready to repay the gifts your
teachers have given you
and share the joy of discovery with
others
you go with our best wishes and our
admiration
congratulations and good luck
you